so this has been a wild ride for you huh
yeah it's been a long road you know
nobody could have
imagined basically from uh looking back
from my life
that we're gonna get here you know today
i have to talk with
uh great people around the world
you know such as you and uh being the
biggest sport
podcast ever you know
and to be about to fight for the ufc
heavyweight championship of the world
too before they suck on time
for the second time yeah yeah the
redemption the redemption
what was the first time like for you
what was was the feeling
of the first fight like for you oh
um i had two different feelings
uh from that fight first uh obviously i
was very
um upset and disappointed that i didn't
win the fight and you know i as
everyone who is fighting for the title
you want to get out there as a
victorious but uh to be honest
i always look in that fight and since uh
the fight day just after the fight i
look at it
and i'm like this is good like um
i learned just too much in that fight
because i even though i was in the level
of fighting for the
world title you know but i still have
some
some missing part in my game and in my
experience i
i remember i was asking my question in
myself like okay
how did it looks like to go into three
rounds
right basically i'm going to a potential
five rounds
that i never been in three rounds how
did it look like
how is it to prepare for this kind of
fight
and i had this fight like six weeks
six weeks earlier so
i was having a lot of questions then
after that fight at night i'm like
okay i get it yeah it's a very big
learning experience right
yeah yeah cause you were smashing
everybody everybody you were knocking
everybody out so
you had these very quick fights yes very
quick very quick rise
and uh didn't spend enough time in the
octagon
to like have those experience even
though
i was almost like you
he was almost four years three years and
a half since i've been
four years that i'd been doing the sport
but
uh didn't spend enough time in the
octagon to have that experience i think
uh in one night i have a uh
it i cover more than what i've been
spending in the octagon from
the rest of my career no no i'm sure
it's um
it's got to be uh a difficult thing to
figure out how to pace yourself for a
five round fight
when you've only been knocking people
out quickly before that
yeah also you know
some people uh get here while they're
being profession when
where they've been having a at least
added
lives for a long time maybe
wrestling maybe doing some different
sport at school
or at college but uh i never get into
that stuff you know
growing up i was just like finding my
way to survive
then i end up finding myself
in somewhere that uh i never been there
you know the so the experience was just
crazy
how old were you when you had your first
training your first uh martial arts
training
oh that was in uh summer october 2013.
that was my first wow yeah so just eight
years ago
yeah and two years after that i was
fighting my first fight in the ufc
and i remember basically like at first
when i went in the martial art
it was just for fun to curiosity i'm
like oh he's fun
oh it's good i like those uh kick [ __ ]
you know but i didn't like
seeing myself being a um
[Music]
ufc fighter and people was like oh if
you put yourself into this
you can become a ufc fighter and a ufc
champion you can have a ufc belt
wrapped around your way so i'm like
whatever you know
you don't care about it until i have the
ufc contract
like two years after that i'm like okay
this might be the opportunity that i
i have been looking for so it's time to
capitalize and uh showcase my talent and
show the world and shock the world
how many fights did you have before you
fought in the ufc six fights
six fights and did you have them all in
france a few fights in france
just four in france i had four friends a
fight in france and
you know in france the ground and pound
is not allowed
when he goes that was back back then
because mma was still illegal so when he
goes on the ground
he's just turned into grappling
grappling game game
really yeah so i had
three a four fight in france one in
switzerland
and one in bahrain
bahrain so when did they find out about
you how did ufc find out about you
um that was um that was my coach fernand
by the time was working with
a a manager named uh thiago
a brazilian guy so they kind of like
push um
thiago has a connection with the i mean
he was a manager so
fernan was all the time sending him a
text message and um videos that
he would uh forward to the ufc
until and i was still like yes but uh he
hasn't fight nobody tough yet
yeah he hasn't get tested uh a real test
yet
until i fought this guy in bahrain named
uh
william badulte and i knocked him out in
the second round
then i gained my ufc control right after
that what was it like the first fight in
ufc
was it different whoa uh
that was a crazy experience you know i
didn't
i didn't even know the rules back then i
remember i was in
uh orlando and i'm like man this is the
time
like i'm going to fight uh
to be seen in the whole world um
so this is my the time to take my
opportunity to showcase
uh my talent to prove that i can do
something then i'm like okay
so what is this up what it is about mma
what how mma works what is the rules how
it goes
and i couldn't get it like they didn't
know the rules but
because you you got used to no ground
fighting punching on the ground
because there's no ground and found in
france yeah even though i was just doing
it for two years and remember
at first he was just for fun right so
didn't really
was there to become a professional
fighter you know
uh all i care about at the time was
boxing
then uh i found myself i found myself
there in two years then i'm like okay
what is the rules again
uh how he works okay uh if he's trying
to take me down i can't do this like
trying to figure all those
out it was very stressful and i'm like
guess what at the end of the day it's
just fine
i mean uh i don't know if this guy is
doing some kung fu [ __ ] but he's just
fighting
we're gonna figure it out you know it's
just men between men
you know right yeah we're gonna figure
out i mean you know i'm a tough guy
you know so i cannot handle it
why did you transition to mma and not
not go into boxing
it's not like a transition and i didn't
have a choice you know i was prac i was
doing mma
because when i get in when i went in
france i was a
i didn't have a paper so i was illegal
so i couldn't work
and i wanted so bad to do
[Music]
sport and i was doing boxing and mma
but the mma was the one that was more
open and giving me opportunity like
having a ufc contract as an mma fighter
was a big deal
and didn't have much you know like
boxing wall it's kind of like a
a very complicated business you have to
know somebody
they have to like line you up it's very
complicated but mma was just easy you
know people
out then i'm like who is that guy we
want that guy it was pretty
pretty easy and made me wise yeah boxing
you have to be connected to the right
promoter
yeah yeah and that takes time yeah and
uh basically uh regarding my situation
back then
uh i had a lot of oats you know
uh coming from nowhere nobody knows me
with my accent
and you know uh in french when you have
accent
it's not a good thing it's not
what's it like over there it's
frustrating because the
the way that they look at you when you
speak with your accent
you know you don't feel comfortable you
can like let
let yourself express yourself you just
feel bad about yourself
you know just seeing people react some
people reaction sometimes
and you didn't have a resident card you
was like
a migrant so it was kind of
together was a tough situation to deal
with
uh basically in the boxing business
because they're gonna go see this
promoter talk about you
but who is that guy where it is come
from oh
you know it's hard to have created from
someone
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely
free you don't have to have a premium
account to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience